vegas test kitchen was designed during
the pandemic to build a home and for a
creative outlet for the talented chefs
in our community and it is headed out on
the road with a special pop-up with two
very talented chefs right now we have
chef gary lemour and chef brian tejada
joining us thanks for coming here guys
thanks for having us i'm excited to have
your culinary expertise here with a
really cool thing that you guys are
doing
at the palms tell us a little bit about
what's going on
well um we've decided to feature some
authentic filipino cuisine uh our
concept is called makatas
and it means succulent or more juicy
and
we're kind of you know doing the
greatest hits of a lot of filipino
classics and really just trying to
express
you know brian's uh upbringing and uh
you know his time growing up in the
philippines and uh you know mix that up
with a little bit of contemporary
restaurant excellence your take on it
yeah chef ryan i filipino food is so
good what are you gonna make for us
today let's let's check it out so we
have quinilao actually uh which is like
our filipino ceviche
we're using fresh ahi tuna
seasoned with our spiced vinegar and
then a little bit of kalamanci which is
native in the philippines
really
mix between lime lemon but it's its own
very own like flavor and
citrus so wow that's beautiful okay
let's say is this hard to make can we
throw this together let's see we can
definitely throw this together so if you
want to scream squeeze some just
yep oh these are so cute i love these do
you see these oh my goodness okay
squeeze a little bit of that just one
like three of them do three okay don't
be shy i i love the juices then we have
some cherry tomatoes
oh all these ingredients are so fresh
you could red onions yeah you could just
smell them
some minced ginger okay
and then for a little kick we have
bird's eye chili can we put an extra
kick in there oh sure i like the kick i
like the kick
some cucumber okay just to balance out
and you guys this is the second week
that you guys are doing this right okay
we have one more week this coming
weekend so we are excited for that and
definitely it's been a fun experience
with the ponds i love it you guys uh
definitely are putting like you said
like that quality ingredients spin on
these classic dishes uh chef gary tell
us a little bit about how people can be
a part of this event
uh well we would suggest going to the
macitas social media on instagram
there's a link there
for reservations we're definitely going
to sell out yeah i'm assuming so
if you're interested i would suggest
going and uh making a reservation today
for friday or saturday night okay
perfect uh now what are we doing here
plate this up the presentation though is
everything look at those colors and
everything i wish you guys could smell
this because it just smells so fresh and
citrusy
and brian's plating in a
authentic filipino
a hand carved monkey pod so it's a
special tree
and it comes from a
region in the philippines
where they're known for ornate wood
carving yeah and look at that this is
just beautiful all right do we get to
take a a bite of this you guys going to
join me is that kick going to kill me am
i going to regret that afterwards no
okay let us know let's see here
um
oh my gosh it is just so fresh and there
is a kick
but it's good i love it
you guys got to check it out make
reservations because like you said it's
definitely going to sell out and where
can where can people try your cuisine
at other times well we've developed this
especially for this event
um so
if you want to give it a whirl you got
to make a reservation oh i'm going to
eat more sorry julian i should try it
with the tarot chips as well oh man i
just like the kick but it's good you're
going to have to have some of this
jillian thank you guys so much for
joining us over to you julian that looks
delicious